you ever heard of an Immaculate grid no
me neither but we're about to play it's
a three by three I see this on Twitter
that's the only place I've ever seen it
what we're supposed to do here is a
player that played for Baltimore and
Cleveland I have no idea none of these
no none of them top of the head
immediately my favorite player Roberto
Alamar there you go you got 11 that's
good is it so 11 of the world think like
me someone that that played with Kansas
City in Cleveland I would go with the
only person I know is no I don't know I
don't know any Kansas City and Cleveland
Kansas City and Cleveland oh Lord what
about 300 wins in Cleveland yeah I told
you I don't know none of them 300 wins
is a lot we're not very good at this
game Matt's in Kansas City Vargas Lefty
Vargas remember Lefty Vargas oh he did
play for both guys
Jason Vargas there you go
yeah three percent you got that one
you're really good at this I'm not